hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
early on in book two of his work on
anger in chapter five Seneca is going to
bring up a very important distinction
between the emotion of anger which can
be very destructive and something that
originates in anger but which goes
beyond it to the extent of making human
beings essentially inhumane and so he
frames it in terms of a question we can
think of it in terms of a assertion on
his part we have to ask whether people
who often behave like animals and the
word that he uses there is Savion which
means to rage like an animal or it's
actually used of animals so people who
behave in this way and who take pleasure
gaudent right who enjoy the shedding of
human blood it doesn't necessarily have
to be blood that we're fixating on this
is kind of a metonymy like a part for
the whole sort of thing it could be
those who enjoy demolishing other people
psychologically it could be those who
enjoy getting people within their power
and playing with them it could be those
who inflict other sorts of physical or
mental anguish upon others but those who
take Delight is another way of
translating gaudent in this and he says
are these people angry
right or is there something else going
on here that sometimes gets confused
with anger and he says
you know if you think about this they
kill people from whom they've not
received an injury or they've not
received a wrong in urea right in urea
is more than just simply damaging
somebody or or you know wounding their
body or something like that nobody is
done wrong to them and they don't even
believe that these others who they're
forcing into the role of a victim
have done so exist Demand right they
don't assess these others as having
harmed them so you can ask well where is
this aggression coming from where is
this desire to harm coming from and he
says you know this um is is not anger
era but a greater evil mayus malam right
a an evil greater than evil or than
anger and since anger is a pretty great
evil for Seneca as he said in other
places this is a really terrible one and
it's an evil that is incurable in
Sanibel it can't be brought back to a
healthy State once a person has
degenerated this far so what what is
this then he says that this is not anger
but what we could translate as either
bestiality or brutality Veritas Wild
this being feral right and it's
interesting that you know with human
beings this ferality takes the form for
Seneca of this incredible aggression
this desire to harm for its own sake or
it can also be understood as another
term that he's going to use here and in
other places in the work as cruelty
could this willingness to inflict pain
not even willingness but a
prioritization a desire to inflict pain
upon other people and now he's going to
note how this is different from anger
we've already seen one key way they
haven't actually received a wrong or
injury and they don't actually think
that they have but they're wanting to
hurt the other person anyway he goes on
and he says that
um they are prepared to receive injury
right in order to do harm to the other
people so that tells you what the the
purpose the point of this is they want
to hurt other people they're cool with
getting hurt themselves if that's what's
required in the process so they're not
doing this because the other person has
hurt them I mean it could be that other
people did hurt them in the past
but this person has them they just want
to do something to them and he says that
they seek to harm others not for the
sake of Vengeance ultionum in ultionum
in Latin but actually for pleasure
voluptas right voluptatum in in this
case so there's a very different let's
call it motivational structure going on
here which differentiates them not just
from run-of-the-mill people who happen
to be angry but even from those who
Seneca has discussed much earlier in the
work in book one those who are irascible
right being irascible means ah you're
touchy you're more likely to to take
offense to get angry to act on your
anger right it's a temperament he's also
going to talk about physical
temperaments here in book two as well
these people have gone further than that
it's no longer anger it's now now
something quite different and he gives
us a really interesting another
Criterion for this by saying these don't
look like angry people literally their
face is not that of an angry person what
does an angry person look like you know
their features are clenched up they've
turned red or pale or whatever other
color they're gnashing their teeth
they're spitting they're doing all these
sorts of things these people are
actually in a different state and he
talks about them for example smiling
right or laughing he talks about them
rejoicing
is the word that he's using there but
we've seen that already here they're
enjoying this they enjoy pleasure
they're literally they they reap the
fruits or of pleasure and of otium
leisure relaxation is another way to
translate it so these are people who are
hurting others deliberately so that they
can enjoy they can smile they can make
themselves calm right and Seneca says
well that's really different than how
people are when they're angry now anger
does lead to this
if you continue it if there's certain
conditions that are met and so this you
know is different than anger but it has
its origin right it arises out of anger
and he talks about a frequent exercise
of anger executio right so we could
translate this as use or attitude
towards anger so when you get angry over
and over and over and over again you are
at risk for that anger ceasing to be
just anger and slowly morphing into
something more dangerous more inhumane
there's uh something else that has to
happen a loss of clemency now you should
remember that Seneca also wrote an
entire book called on clemency right
clementia this capacity to overlook to
forgive to take offenses and disregard
them or to let them go right to get over
them you could say so when we lose that
and we also slowly lose the memory of
our human bonds for example those
connecting us to the human race in
general to our neighbors to our friends
to our family to our co-workers to you
know people who are connected with us in
other ways when we cease to look at them
as fellow human beings and we start to
look at them as objects for our
discharge of anger aggressiveness we
might even say sadism over time then
what we see happening
is there's a transformation that takes
place he says Transit it goes over into
crudeletas or cruelty right and he says
um you know this has its start from from
anger and then it turns into something
some you know much much worse so that's
the process by which it happens and then
he gives a bunch of examples here he
gives us the example of apollodorus a
tyrant who implicated other people in
cannibalism making them take part in
that so that his supporters would he
would have something over them that's
cruelty not just to them but the victims
to fallaris fallaris is very famous for
having created a Brazen Bull in which
the victims of his cruelty were put
inside the bull would be heated up they
would literally roast to death within it
and they would be screaming and there
was a sort of you know apparatus to turn
their screams into piping and everybody
would you know gather around and kind of
laugh at this as somebody was literally
being burned or roasted to death that's
some hardcore cruelty there he talks
about Hannibal somebody who would be
very familiar to the Romans as not only
you know the great enemy of Rome who is
a brilliant General but also as somebody
who is incredibly
cruel right so he tells us here Hannibal
seeing a ditch filled with human blood
he remarked what a lovely sight again
there's that taking Delight in human
Bloodshed how much Lovelier Seneca says
would he have found it if he felt some
river or lake and he says now he's
talking to Hannibal is it any wonder
you're beguiled by this site above all
seeing that you were born to Bloodshed
and became an intimate of murder from
your intimacy for 20 years luck will
attend you supporting your cruelty and
ever show you sights to please your eye
uh around Lake trasumine and around
canine finally around your own City
Carthage where he's he's defeated right
and so it's interesting because Seneca
here is saying you know you couldn't be
otherwise look at how you were brought
up uh you know delighting in Bloodshed
and so you became a general in part so
you could shed other people's blood and
demand them
um he talks about as well and valesses
he says decapitated 300 men in one day
Strode about the corpses with a haughty
look as if he'd accomplished something
Splendid and wondrous exclaiming in
Greek such a kingly deed and then Seneca
says what would this guy have done if he
was actually a king this was not anger
at work but some greater evil right so
this cruelty that this guy has and you
notice one of the common elements here
that it's not just a matter of those
exercising cruelty but it's also an
exercise of power over others a power
that destroys a power that tortures a
power that sheds blood for the sake of
seeing that Bloodshed and I will point
out that these are some some you know on
point examples here in book three Seneca
is going to discuss a number of other
examples of Cruelty and fruality or
bestiality or brutality one of the ones
that really sticks out is quite late in
book three talking about Augustus
visiting vedius polio vedius polio was a
guy who had lampreys or moray eels or
something like that in a big pool
and you know he's he's fattening them up
and the way he's fattening him up is
serving them human beings so there's a
slave who breaks a cup and the Crystal
cup so you know something a little
precious and vedius uh this is you know
Seneca calls it an unprecedented cruelty
orders that the slave be thrown to these
eels bitten to death eaten up alive
right in front of the emperor and
Augustus is like smash all this guy's
Crystal what is wrong with you now this
is an interesting case because as we've
seen Seneca is telling us that this is
an incurable disease at this point he
actually tells us that um
this is the sort of anger I've described
beastial monstrous bloodthirsty on the
point
of being incurable if something's still
greater doesn't give it a good scare
Augustus in this case is more powerful
and he's exercising power on this other
person and you know we get a lot of
examples of Kings or military leaders
who are doing things that show this kind
of Cruelty to others he talks about
Darius the Persians Xerxes he talks
about you know cambases as well he talks
about Alexander the Great he's doing
this as a way to give you know a dig to
Aristotle Alexander does some bad things
he also does some you know
traumatization you could say of his
friends like listen Alyssa Marcus who
became a a you know terrible person as
well when he'd done the job of pruning
to lesser forests of Roads cutting his
ears and nose he put him in a cage like
some sort of animal
um he'd added wasting hunger squalor
filth of his body you know his hands and
knees in this cage
um grew calloused pads and and so he
turns this human being you know somebody
who he had fought against into just a
complete caricature of a human being and
we get some you know uh Roman examples
as well uh Gaia Caesar uh gets talked
about quite a bit
um and so you know these are these are
examples of the kind of Cruelty that
Seneca thinks we can develop into if we
have the power over others and if we go
down this line of frequent exercise of
anger losing a Humane sense of of
clemency or forgiveness and our human
bonds we can be transformed into these
horrific human beings that do you know
choose to do desire to do prioritize do
doing damage harm torture and imposing
death on other people so this is very
different from but does arise from anger
according to Seneca